viens donc de me rejoindre sur ce
plateau nicolas kirillovitch bonsoir
bonsoir cette journaliste pour radio
sensations la station qui émet dans le
département sur le 98.4 ceux qui étaient
avec nous la semaine dernière vous ont
suivi ils ont suivi vous compte rendu de
l'actualité et des yvelinois au festival
de cannes depuis la croisette vous avez
aussi réalisé pour radio sensations une
édition spéciale du rendez vous
hebdomadaire d'actualité de votre
rédaction un zeste d'infos un zeste d'un
fossé chaque dimanche à 19h et ce soir
pour t'aider fils vous allez nous faire
un bilan de cette grand'messe annuelle
du cinéma international
on va bien sûr parler de ceux qui
viennent du 78e qui résiste encore mais
déjà un mot sur les projections auquel
vous avez assisté forcément quand on va
à cannes on assiste à la projection
ouais et bien j'ai retenu deux films que
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir et notamment
un film de la sélection officielle très
drôle et très bien réalisé ma vie avec
libera ce avec dans les rôles principaux
matt damon et michael douglas ce film
c'est il raconte en fait la vraie vie
d'une star du piano des années 70 avec
tout ce que ça peut comporter des
mesures argent et histoires amoureuses
un peu loufoque
alors c'est rempli de clichés et de
stéréotypes sur les stars et sur les
gays mais c'est très amusant autre film
qui m'a marqué présenté cette fois ci
hors compétition officielle c'est all is
lost avec comme seul et unique
personnage robert redford
l'acteur américain il joue le rôle d'un
homme d'un marin dont le voyait cool et
qui doit affronter une mer déchaînée
pour tenter de survivre dans ce film en
tout et pour tout je crois il ya juste
deux phrases mais c'est prenant tout de
même on a envie que ce marin soit sauvé
tellement il est courageux face à toutes
les péripéties qu'il affronte vous ne
vous êtes pas endormi pendant la noce
même s'il n'ya que deux phrases
bon ça tirait le contraire cannes c'est
aussi des soirées forcément très couru
et ne mentez pas vous irez participer
oui et je ne mens pas j'en garde un très
très bon souvenir alors c'est soirée est
organisée sur des plages privées avec un
accès contrôlé pour y entrer c'était
assez compliqué ne fallait pas perdre
patience mais une fois à l'intérieur on
n'est jamais déçu avec des concerts tous
les soirs
m joey starr phoenix qui sont d'ailleurs
des yvelinois et une ambiance bon enfant
à tous les coups vraiment de
très bonne soirée mais voilà des images
on peut voir comment comment se sont
déroulées ces soirées projections
soirées cannoises et puis également
montée des marches
vous avez eu l'occasion d'accéder au
palais des festivals par le tapis rouge
accompagné d'ailleurs d'un des
collaborateurs de radio sensations c'est
franck et d'art que les gens le
connaissent forcément vous l'avez sans
doute reconnu sur ces images puisqu'il
est journaliste pour m6 et pour le clin
d'oeil
19 45 est programmé en même temps que le
7 8 mais bon c'est toujours les replays
pour assister aux deux émissions si vous
voulez tout savoir de l'actualité
oui ça aussi ça restera un excellent
souvenir c'est le moment un peu on va
dire magique du festival ces fameuses
marches rouges avec tous les
photographes et toutes les télés du
monde entier sur les côtés bon c'est
bizarre mais avec tant qu'on n'a pas été
beaucoup pris en photo pour voit sur les
images qu'on avait pourtant on est bien
habillé on est sur notre 31 d'ailleurs
sachez que pour monter les marches le
noeud papillon est obligatoire pour les
hommes sinon c'est par l'issue de
secours que l'on rentre et là ça fait
tout de suite un petit peu moins ce
serait dommage en plus d'aller à cannes
et de rester coincée en bas des marches
alors sinon il y avait des yvelinois un
qui était présent au festival est aussi
ont eu la chance de monter les marches
oui c'est le cas d'elena soubeyrand
originaire de saint-germain-en-laye
elena faisait partie cette année de la
sélection en talents adami 2013 cette
sélection permet à des jeunes comédiens
de jouer dans des courts métrages
projetés au festival au palais des
festivals et donc d'être sous le feu des
projecteurs
elena jouer dans on ne badine pas avec
rosette l'histoire d'une troupe de
théâtre aux jeux blizzard est un peu
étrange qui accueille une nouvelle
actrice mais je vous le disais ce qui a
beaucoup marqué et l'ena c'est sa
première montée des marches on écoute
quand on entend dans notre nom sur ce
grand tapis et conques est tellement
mythique avec ce tapis rouge le festival
de cannes marc angrand je vois que
depuis tout petit c'est vraiment un truc
hein on s'est dit c'est abc yella jeu là
je suis devant je suis jeune et j'ai les
boules tapis sous les pieds ça est vrai
prince est très fort ex trice des
acteurs et aussi des réalisateurs des
réalisatrices parmi les jeunes
réalisateurs des yvelines à cannes qui
était présent c'est quentin dupuis oui
quentin qui présenté au short film
corner l'espace dédié aux courts
métrages dans le palais des festivals le
temps d'un repas un film qu'il a écrit
et réalisé
petit extrait de sa bande annonce c'est
fini
à toronto merci à tous nos sens
je
c'est compliqué pour tous
c'est juste pas des fois j
mais pas si différente et moi obasi
johnson
oh
ok moi
ce qui est amusant avec quentin c'est
qu'il vient de plaisir la même ville que
guillaume canet et jean dujardin et
forcément ce point en commun avec eux
lui donne quelques idées
c'est vrai que ça fait rêver déjà parce
qu'ivan à côté de chez moi et c'est
quand on voit le parcours international
guillaume canet jean dujardin c'est
vraiment un peu le rêve france pour
beaucoup de cinéastes notamment pour moi
de pouvoir se dire qu'avoir une carriè
vraiment internationale tant en france
que dans les pays anglo saxons aux etats
unis c'est vrai que c'est un peu le un
peu le rêve un acteur financier cette
fois-ci présent à cannes c'est la région
ile de france oui la région qui soutient
énormément le cinéma sans un film ont
été tournées en ile de france l'an
dernier et près de 15 millions d'euros
ont été versés à l'industrie du cinéma
la présence de la région était donc
indispensable au festival de cannes
comme nous l'expliquent olivier thomas
conseillère régionale ici on vient
naturellement à la rencontre des
producteurs des réalisateurs de ceux qui
on travaille au quotidien pour faire
cette politique du cinéma qui environ
a donné une création de 8000 emplois
dans l'est en 2011 c'est ce qu'on a
compté sur l'île de france donc c'est
énorme comme politique d'emploi voilà
pour ce résumé du festival de cannes du
côté des yvelinois deux côtés des
franciliens avec nikola kirillovitch
merci de radio sensations on vous
retrouve sur l'antenne 98 4 1 dans les
yvelines
régulièrement c'est ça tout les grandes
manches tous les dimanches un zeste
d'infos 19 heures voilà j'ai perdu ma
mère